بالعوده الى عدو سكان خرسان وميكو لايف
الجديد الشتاء القارس يحاول الاهالي
التفادي مغادره بيوتهم باحثين عما توفره
الطبيعه لمواجهه البرد الحطب البديل
الطبيعي للكهرباء لكن جلبه ليس بالامر
الهين ايضا حذرت سلطات الاوكرانيه
المواطنين من التوجه الى الغابات دون
استشاره الجيش لان القوات الروسيه ربما
تركت وراءها الغاما واسلاكا اسلاكن قد
تعثرهم وقذف غير منفجره لكن مع ارتفاع
اسعار الحطب لم يعد امام كثيرين خيار سوى
المخاطره
اذا لم يقتلهم لغم فقد يكون البرد هو
القاتل الجديد لكن ان كان الشتاء ليس في
صالح الاوكرانيين فلا يعني انه في صالح
الروس ايضا الذين سيواجهون الصعوبه بنقل
المعدات عبر الطين والثلج والجليد في سهول
الدمباز التي تفتحها الرياح هناك حيث يمكن
ان تنخفض درجات الحراره الى 30 درجه مئويه
ناقص اي تحت الصفر وفقا لمسؤولين امريكيين
فان قرار الكراملين بالانسحاب من خرصان
سند جزئيا الى مخاوفه من ان الامدادات
ستنقطع عن الجنود مع حلول فصل الشتاء قبل
اربعه ايام كان الرئيس الاوكراني اكثر
وضوحا في محادثه له مع صحفيين قال اذا
بقينا على قيد الحياه هذا الشتاء اذا
بقينا سنفعل ذلك فستنتصر اوكرانيا
بالتاكيد في هذه الحرب
[موسيقى]
لكن لمكسيم ما تمشينكو رئيس شركه دي تي اي
وهي اكبر شركه كهرباء اوكرانيه خاصه له
راي اخر
مفاجئ اذا طلب من المدنيين مغادره
اوكرانيا هذا الشتاء اذا استطعت وذلك
لمساعده البلاد في التعامل مع ازمه الطاقه
لجميع سكانها للبقاء في فصل الشتاء لان
الهجمه الصاروخيه الروسيه دمرت البنيه
التحتيه الرئيسه في حديث نهايه الاذاعه
البريطانيه اذا تمكنوا من العثور على مكان
البديل للاقامه لمده ثلاثه او اربعه اشهر
اخرى فسيكون ذلك مفيدا مفيدا جدا